these roadblocks on the streets and
neighborhoods around sudan's capital
khartoum are now a common site
once used to keep out security forces
during anti-government protests against
then president umar al-bashir in 2019
they've become a symbol of rejection of
monday's military coup
and on the third day of the military
takeover in albara the city where the
revolution that overthrew bashir started
people were back on the streets
[Music]
in khartoum protesters have called for a
general strike and civil disobedience
state oil workers doctors businesses and
other sectors have responded to that
call
malls banks government institutions and
private companies are all closed this is
a full civil strike and people are
preparing for the main event on october
30th
these people were elected because we saw
that they had the know-how but the
military didn't give them the space to
do their jobs right now because the
military has power they have halted the
path and taken us back to square one but
that doesn't work for us
this is why it's better than al-burhan
reverses his decisions the coup has
already had an economic and political
impact on sudan the u.s has announced it
will hold back a 700 million assistance
package that was meant for the
transitional government that has been
deposed the african union suspended
sudan's membership on wednesday and the
world bank which provided financial
assistance has withheld that too
lieutenant general abdel fattah
al-burhan said he took power and
dissolved the cabinet to avoid sliding
into civil war he's promised a cabinet
of professionals but some analysts say
forming a government accepted by all
will not be easy if they manage to come
up with
an acceptable
government government that is formed
with a real expert who are independent
from political affiliations who can be
trusted to take the country into
election
in 2023 or 24 as it was stipulated
before i think that will be the key
these demonstrators say they'll continue
to build their momentum for more
protests calling for an end to the
military rule several people have been
killed since the coup on monday and many
more injured but protesters say they'll
go on until their aims are achieved hiba
morgan al jazeera khartoum